what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are in kind of a weird spot
we have about six weeks until we need to
upload the return of Thanos after a
second death which goes directly into
the pre Lu tooth anos quests which goes
directly into Infinity Gauntlet yes I
have infinity gauntlet part eight yes I
have two Anna's quest parts one into you
I originally had to take them down for
copyright reasons but that's since been
sorted out so at this point I'm just
waiting to re-upload those which means
that we kind of have like six weeks to
kill and so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna upload earth X we're gonna do the
earth x series now or at least just the
earth X story I'm gonna test this so I'm
gonna see how you guys respond to it
because I don't know if people will
really enjoy it or if people are
definitely like a small handful of
people that are really even like
remotely interested in it but earth X is
really really good earth X is actually
the story that basically deals with the
answer to the question what would happen
if everybody on earth had superpowers
what would happen to the Marvel Universe
and how would the heroes deal with it as
it was basically a dystopian future
story and it's actually really really
interesting now there is a prelude in
terms of how all this took place and
what all happened in terms of how
everyone gained power is all that kind
of stuff we'll cross that bridge when we
get to it for right now I'm not gonna
cover the pre loot I'm gonna do that at
the end I'm gonna make you guys wait but
what this initially does is this picks
up with Captain America Steve Rogers and
this basically tells the origin story of
his character and that's something that
I want you guys to notice with this
earth X the way this initially picks up
is the origin stories for the characters
are largely the same they're larger the
the kind of stories were familiar with
there's small changes here and there but
largely for the most part the origin
stories are still the same for example
Steve Rogers took the Super Soldier
Serum and became Captain America he
eventually went on to fight against the
Red Skull during World War Two and the
various you know German powers and so on
and so forth and then what we ended up
having was the drone plane explosion now
here's a big difference between Earth X
and the main Marvel Universe when it
comes to the drone plane explosion the
way this originally happened this was
done by Baron Zemo but there's nothing
to indicate the Baron Zemo is actually
here we're kind of left to believe he is
but it's really one of those things
where it's traced back to the Red Skull
and so because of that we can largely
just kind of assumed the Red Skull was
behind the whole thing which he kind of
was when it came to the original drone
plane crash the difference here is that
in the original crash
Captain America fell down into the ocean
he was basically you know frozen and ice
for however many years and then Bucky
bar and survived the explosion and was
captured by the Russians and turned into
the Winter Soldier in this story the
indication is that didn't have
Bucky Barnes died he's gone he's no
longer part of the equation here now
following this what ended up happening
is we basically had Captain America who
came back the Red Skull of course who
rose to prominence once again we had the
other story where the Red Skull gained a
Cosmic Cube the difference of what's not
necessarily covered directly in this
instead it's actually covered in the
backup pages it's kind of like an
exchange between the two characters who
were chronically in this whole thing
what we ended up finding out is that
Captain America somewhere along the line
killed the Red Skull and so the Red
Skull is basically dead or at least
that's the indication and so what it
does is kind of jumped to the modern-day
now again this story is kind of being
given to us by two individuals and I'll
reveal who those are once we get to the
end of this whole thing but what we end
up doing here is picking up with like
the return of the Inhumans and the
Inhumans had basically left earth for
reasons that we'll find out later on in
this story but the Inhumans showing back
up really comes by way of the royal
marriage between Luna and the prints now
Luna is the daughter of Crystal and
Quicksilver if you don't know who
Crystal is not a great big huge deal
she's basically just a member of the
inhuman royal family and then of course
Quicksilver the son of magneto in Marvel
Comics in the main Marvel Universe they
did have a child named Luna what this
story does is take place around 20 years
in the future so and basically say we
end up having the Inhumans making the
return in order to kind of you know
engage in this royal marriage the
problem is that when the Inhumans show
back up everything has really gone to
pot Attilan is just kind of left in
shambles and no one really knows we're
like super-powered people are at least
they don't know we're super-powered
people are we're like The Avengers or
the x-men or any of those folks are at
and so what they end up doing is taking
up residence and traveling directly to
New York in order to figure out what's
going on so what we do is we basically
join up with what seems to be just a
city of New York
that's just filled with all these
super-powered beings but what's
happening here is there's kind of a
reshaping of things taking place to a
degree in the sense that what you have
is this kind of Hydra alien now this is
one of those weird scenarios because in
the main Marvel Universe Hydra basically
broke off from the Germans it was
founded by Baron von Strucker his
ideologies were starkly different from
the Germans and that's one of the
reasons why he became an enemy of that
group at the same time outlying himself
at the hand and then just kind of going
off and doing his own thing because of
this in Earth X there really is no Hydra
in the sense that we're familiar with
with Baron von Strucker
instead there's just kind of like the
Hydra organism and what this thing is
done is somewhere along the line began
bonding itself to various people one of
the most
we'll be Jennifer Walters she-hulk and
what it does is it basically kind of
takes over people in their entirety and
brings them into a kind of hive mind
collective much like the actual like
Hydra organization itself something else
to notice here is that Steve Rogers as
we see him is vastly different than the
Captain America that were used to one of
the things that had taken place here is
that when Steve Rogers is basically
being Captain America the country had
rallied under him now much like in the
main Marvel Universe in Captain America
number 250 I think Steve Rogers ran for
president of the United States where the
very least was offered the opportunity
to run for president of the United
States the difference is that unlike the
main Marvel Universe where he ran in
this story he doesn't run he actually
rejects the whole thing and the issue
with this is that the American people
see him as rejecting America and so as a
result Captain America loses popularity
and that's one of the reasons why his
outfits so tattered he looks kind of
like you know like he's a man that's
just struggled over and over and over
again he's really seen some things not
only that we end up finding out then
he's not necessarily paired up with
Falcon instead Falcon had actually been
absorbed into this Hydra organism
whatever it is instead he's paired up
with Wyatt Wingfoot now Wyatt Wingfoot
is a character the dates all the way
back to the early days of the Fantastic
Four so if you haven't heard about him
don't feel bad because in truth he
hasn't been a relevant character for
something like 50 years but Wyatt
Wingfoot was basically kind of like a
like a mascot for the Fantastic Four to
a degree he was a close friend he would
help them on missions different things
like that but he had no real powers he
was just kind of a guy who was there and
so the idea is that he basically becomes
Red Wing at least that's the name that's
given to him he kind of becomes the new
Falcon so this was pretty a pretty
insane here because we end up having the
actual Falcon basically speaking to
Captain America by way of this you know
Hydra entity saying hey look you have to
join us you should show up you should
become part of our group and we're
Captain America and Wyatt kind of fight
against these forces the group has
suddenly met with the arrival of Cyclops
and this is an older Cyclops when he's
older he's great he's not part of the
x-men you know as far as we're aware the
x-men don't really seem to exist instead
what we're told is that somewhere along
the line the x-men had effectively
disbanded and Charles Xavier had died so
the group's not really there anymore
following that we switch over to a Peter
Parker and Peter Parker again kind of a
guy who's in his 40s you know basically
an aging guy is told by Sargent Luke
Cage hey look you have to get out of
here Tony Stark is implementing one of
these purges of course you also have may
Parker who's kind of watching the events
unfold wearing the actual spider
fit but that's when we end up finding
out here that this is attempt by the
Hydra entity to basically infiltrate New
York and conquer the city in its
entirety is a repeating pattern it seems
to happen almost every single day and
every single day Tony Stark sends out
these life model decoy Avengers and they
go through and they quote-unquote purge
you know this Hydra entity and basically
running out of town until it comes back
and tries to repeat the same process
again but that's the nature of things
because what we end up having is Steve
Rogers who is basically able to break
away a piece of the clothing of one of
the individuals who've been brought in
by this Hydra entity and Steve Rogers
reveals that what's on this this this
cloth is a Red Skull insignia now this
is where things really begin to get
crazy what we end up doing here is
actually following up with these two
individuals who are chronically in the
Fantastic Four
now the Fantastic Four origin is exactly
the way that always was the idea that
Reed Richards was more obsessed with
like the pursuit of knowledge you know
different things like that which led him
taking Ben Grimm and Susan storm and
Johnny Storm onto a spacecraft they flew
into space
they were bombarded by cosmic rays and
they gained their powers the difference
here is that somewhere along the line
Reed Richards had basically discovered
the nature of vibranium in the sense
that when he was presumably invited by
Black Panther to Wakanda and read sort
of deduced that vibranium was
extraterrestrial in nature and so what
he began doing was kind of setting up
these transportation tubes that were
designed to basically eliminate the
entire need for energy across the world
using vibranium as a source and that's
really all we get because what we end up
doing is picking up with the Inhumans
when they basically traveled to Yancy
Street to where Ben Grim's located at of
course with Adam warlock and hizmet
rather who are essentially just kind of
leaving the house of Ben Grimm those are
guys who don't know ah you saw kismet in
guardians of the galaxy - that was the
chick who was like you know the leader
of whatever that group was who was all
gold though the whole basis behind this
was you know when we talked about Adam
warlock before we kind of revealed the
idea that Adam warlock was created by a
group called the hive who were basically
held in on creating like the perfect
being and we're out of Morlock
essentially he made his escape turned
against the hive took off you know for
parts unknown and then you know his
whole story unfolded in terms of his you
know inclusion with Thanos and different
things like that that what was also
created was a being called her which
basically became kismet and they were
designed to be mates and so what this
does is essentially revealed that the
two of them have found one another and
they have effectively become mates not
only that what we end up doing is
picking up with Ben
and his family now the cool thing about
this is that Ben Grimm is married to
Alicia masters and Alicia masters has
basically gained powers which is to say
the ability to bring things to life now
this is important because Alicia masters
as originally a woman who is blind but
was a gifted sculptor and what this
meant was that she could basically
sculpt anything she could make you know
things look almost real life and then
interned with the power she has now
bring them to life and that's how the
family of Ben Grimm basically comes to
fruition the actions of Alicia masters
allows her to take the clay and then
mold it into like children basically of
Ben Grimm and herself and then bring
them to life all these different
artifacts these things that you see here
the moldings of spider-man The Moorings
of Captain America the Morley's of dr.
Doom's head all that's done by Alicia
masters and it's pretty cool because
while they're all sitting down around
the dinner table the question that comes
from the Inhumans is where are the
Fantastic Four one of the world's going
on here well what we end up finding out
is that somewhere along the line during
this 20 year window dr. doom had
essentially launched a campaign due to
the fact that there was a huge meeting
between the United Nations and it was
dr. Doom's attempt to effectively
capture the world's food resources to
essentially say if you control resources
you control the world and dr. doom had
actually brought name with us
submariners who aside by arguing that
when humanity takes into account what
they're going to do with this global
food shortage at no point will they take
into account Atlantis instead they will
think only about what benefits the
surface world and so we effectively
joined dr. doom in order to curtail that
whole discussion in the first place and
so as a result the Fantastic Four
responded Captain America responded so
on and so forth and it led him to a
pretty significant battle between the
two groups but where Johnny Storm went
to try to stop Namor the Submariner
Namor basically killed him he stabbed
him with his Trident and in response
Franklin Richards freaked out he
basically used his powers of
reality-warping to condemn Namor the
Submariner to burn on one half of his
body for all eternity the only way for
him to basically not burn on one half is
to jump down into the oceans and that's
kind of where it keeps him at the moment
it keeps him underwater so that he's not
literally burning on one side but
because of the fact that Susan storm and
Johnny Storm were so close as brother
and sister Susan storm loses it as well
and so what ends up happening is she
chases after dr. doom immediately goes
after him he leads her into a trap and
then detonates the entire facility
killing dr. doom himself and Susan storm
and so that all that's really left here
is Franklin Richards were given no
indication valaria Richards the daughter
of
of read and Susan is actually alive and
instead all we have is just Ben Grimm
and Reid and that's where things begin
to get kind of crazy because the
question is asked well then whatever
happened to Reed Richards you know where
in the world is Reed Richards at and so
what we end up learning here is that
Reed Richards in his attempt to kind of
deal with the gravity of the situation
but to also huge the almost limitless
resources of Victor Von Doom based on a
Latveria he basically took on dooms
Armour and then took up residence in
Latveria and so Reed Richards basically
became Doctor Doom and it's really cool
it's such an awesome idea it's such an
awesome concept but Reed has really
overcome with the whole situation is
just kind of sitting there and almost on
the verge of giving up because what he
does is speak with Tony Stark a day
after day in terms of trying to find a
way to figure out what went on with
regards to everybody gaining powers how
everybody got abilities in the first
place all they know is it has something
to do with the overload of vibranium but
nobody really knows how they simply know
that Reed built this massive system that
vibranium was used as a conduit
basically as an energy source that
somehow it overloaded something went
wrong and everybody gained powers across
the world and so the idea of Reed is you
know really to kind of like find a cure
it's to find a way to fix this but
notice this whole thing and this is
something that I want you guys to keep
in mind notice this when it comes to
this whole scenario its superheroes
trying to return things to the status
quo well the world was better when only
we had powers the world was not better
when everyone had powers it's one of
those interesting things it's kind of
like a fear of change in terms of how
that whole thing happens and so it is
cool the issue is that Reed's been
trying to figure it out all this time
but hasn't come to a conclusion he's
just kind of stuck in this rut of
dealing with this emotional crushing you
know the fact that he lost Susan storm
the fact that he lost Johnny storm the
fact that Ben Grimm kind of abandoned
the Fantastic Four ideology went off
started his own family kind of left it
all behind that's really where all this
is kind of coming from for the character
of Reed and so what we end up doing is
switching over to this sort of carnival
that's going on in terms of this group
can you see you know do you want to come
see the new daredevil can you kill the
new daredevil that's really the whole
idea and they subject him to a wide
array of different forms of torture you
know whether it's fire something along
those lines and this guy survives each
and every time and so the result is that
where he's supposed to basically be set
on fire and then impaled and that's
really supposed to be about it instead
the entire scenario is met by this
massive amount of people who all show up
at the same time you know a lot of these
like superheroes who just kind of pop up
onto the scene and basically say hey
look you guys are all under the control
of the Red Skull now this all belongs to
us everything belongs to the skull
either you can ally with this or you can
die that's really the only ultimatum
that's given to them but again it's
crazy so a couple things that I want to
I want to kind of wrap into this a
couple things that I want to discuss
about this for a second the first is the
state of government so the United States
government in this story has effectively
collapsed there's no more Congress
there's no more White House there's
basically Norman Osborn who's
essentially president he has absolute
power and everything is basically run by
corporations let's really run by like
Norman Osborn himself and so if it
doesn't have a financial incentive then
no one cares none of the court none of
the corporations care you know and so
again it's it's pretty wild in terms of
how this whole thing unfold the story
only ever gets better from here it just
it gets absolutely bonkers oh my god
then you get into Universe X and then
you get into paradise X dude I love I
love like I think Earth X is the best of
them but like universe X is actually
pretty solid like it's it's pretty all
dude what'd you guys get - the Galactus
reveal oh man dude you guys are gonna
freak out when we get to the reveal of
Galactus at the end of the story dude
okay those are guys who read that when I
saw that almost like oh my god Gordon do
not show people who Galactus is in earth
at if I see a Galactus panel pop up on
here there's gonna men you're gonna be
in a world of hurt like I'm really
excited to see the Galactus reveal oh
dude I'm so dude I'm actually trying to
read the comments on the Galactus reveal
but anyway guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comets explain make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the Rob
cork if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]